I'm shaking I feel like I'm about to
pass out for her to make us go through
all this Hassle and then to back out at
the last minute one thousand pound
Sisters star Tammy Slaton gets cold feet
on her wedding day I don't know if I'm
gonna be able to walk in
the reality stars Journey to the altar
was front and center on Tuesday's
episode of the TLC series a year ago
I didn't even think I was gonna be alive
and now I'm getting married the lucky
guy Caleb Willingham who Tammy's
families never met Caleb and Tammy got
engaged just weeks after meeting at a
weight loss treatment center and when
you move fast it can raise eyebrows
which is exactly what happened with
Tammy's siblings hey perky
shotgun wedding nobody's having a
shotgunway well I mean it is awful soon
the heck I'm pregnant Tammy's sisters
Amanda and Misty do finally meet Caleb
and they don't hold back treat her good
because if you don't
you will not like us
if it's a snake in the grass we just cut
the head off okay
that's how we roll Amanda is kind of
scary but when you love somebody you
don't let anything get in the way as
Tammy's wedding day arrives she's
excited but nervous and isn't sure she
can say I do can I do this
you can tell this has been a little much
for her I don't know if I'm gonna be
able to walk in
right now
I'm not sure what's going on
I don't know if there's cold feet
I don't know their second thoughts
she better not be at rollaway bride but
Tammy does eventually make it down the
aisle I saw Caleb at the altar
are this picture does and butterflies
all around and like
God has opened up clouds and let the
sunlight in
that's magical by the power vested in me
from the Universal Life Church in the
state of Ohio I present Caleb and Tammy
Willingham
I'm ready
the reception was full of memorable
moments including this one courtesy of
Tammy's sister Amy hey Caleb welcome to
the family bro
and I've been holding in this part
[Music]
I mean so long-winded she broke wind
coming in I was skeptical in Caleb and I
still am but it made a little bit better
knowing than he is here for Tammy and he
does love her
isn't too soon yes but at the end of the
day she's came a long way congrats to
Tammy and Caleb cheers
foreign